like I was like I was just freaking
unloading on him like he was on a verge
of death and then like we broke apart
like he was holding on for dear life and
then we finally broke apart and my head
was like all right let's finish this guy
and I walked and all of a sudden I
closed my eyes I woke up and I'm like
did I just lose
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys
where Nick we're currently off the
Record we're off the Record wow you
sound so official yeah sounded like the
hype train went down huh well you seemed
you seemed like disappointed when I said
it off the Record usually this one it
was disappointing take two come on try
it again more importantly we have Ron
skulls game here let's give it up for
Ron
run run
that was good
I'm happier hey everybody uh online has
like loved us like putting up different
Asians against each other and comparing
them and stuff like that would you be
able to rank all Asian fight styles from
best source or Worse Asian fight Styles
dang okay can we start at the bottom can
we uh what's the Wacker do you need to
write him down yeah can we generate a
list on Google yeah
hey that's cheating that's not very
Asian of you
kind of hard dude someone top tier bro
yeah that's kind of legit yeah I'm kind
of interested in that new Sumo Netflix
show really they have a Netflix show dog
watching Sumo Fighters some more
wrestlers like actually compete they're
doing some hardcore [__] that [__] is
tight I've seen an entire competition
it's exciting there was some super
Fighters and pride yeah experience yeah
it's better it's better than slap
fighting bro for sure see talking down
on Sumo where's Tai Chi where's Tai Chi
is that a martial art oh yeah it's like
oh my Lord you really went there no we
know where this starts then yes on the
bottom
Hey where's where's Aikido
that's not that's not like Steven Seagal
[__] it's totally Steven Seagal yeah
it is it is so tough because so many of
my friends are like black belts and
Aikido are they yeah is it easy to get
oh
he's like everyone I know is like you
know it is so theoretical oh really it
is very theoretical like like if Anthony
was like punch me like right here though
really slow you want me to punch you
yeah very slowly and then I'd be like if
I kept going you would have broke your
arm and then you would have had a black
belt yeah and that's aikido oh so it's
more about like you telling them what's
gonna happen
um not necessarily I mean that's what
they do during class this I would have
done this and dislocated this but no I
have I have a force field no other hand
other hand no other collar oh damn yeah
you could have died yeah it's like oh
you would have died if I did that yeah
it's a lot of theoretical stuff but it's
confusing because there's Aikido there's
hop keto hop keto is a little bit
different there's hip hop keto too
now that's legit he knows that one
is that like Korean karate I believe it
is with a little bit of Judo in it I
think it's similar to Judo yeah yeah it
is I did a little bit of hot keto but I
think it's because my Korean taekwondo
Master was just trying to fish different
ways to get more money
so what did you what would you do in
class Taekwondo is [__] good up there
they're really good kind of like a cult
is Taekwondo on the upper or lower tiers
Target was like Scientology
it depends there's hardcore Taekwondo
practitioners and then there's
the normal ones that you get a black
belt like in six months
[Laughter]
one is the demos where they just kick a
bunch of like really small and they do
backflips and they do crazy stuff like
oh but that's just still crazy that's
what I'm saying it's enjoyable
jump off of people's shoulders yeah yeah
it's not meant like for actual combat
but like it's entertaining I think a
good criteria is is if there's actual
competition between like two people
fighting the other version of Taekwondo
I love is because you always see those
like the early MMA videos where it's
like taekwondo Master versus like Jiu
Jitsu whatever the Taekwondo got always
gets [__] up into Jitsu that's a tough
eyebrow that's a tough what's that one
Israeli one that's like
is that upper two or lower tier that'll
totally f up a person that has no idea
what they're doing like because
everything is like just eye gouges and
nut shots yeah it's very theoretical
yeah everything is just like lethal
lethal shots it's it's tough because I
would say for self-defense any of those
martial arts would be beneficial except
maybe the touchless one what's that you
mean this one where they look at you
yeah oh [__]
God damn oh the Bluetooth ones
have you guys seen the one where the
ladies the ladies on the beach and it's
like they're all a bunch of white people
on the beach punch me and then she's
like all right get your Chi ready and
then she's like getting ready and the
guy like runs at her full clip any
[__] destroys her barrels anywhere
yeah yeah and she's like 50 something
she was supposed to stop it with with
Chi yeah the wall right and she gets
[__] a blue and the sounds she makes
when she gets hit is like oh satisfied
so bad no no you ever hear like a bug
hit your windshield yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was it like the grape uh [__]
Vineyard girl lady yeah
it's kind of like that actually it's
very similar and then and then the guy's
like well you should have [__] had
your horse
so what's your what do you think is
number one let's maybe go the other way
as far as martial arts
foreign
I'm saying two fighters of this esteemed
style in a room different you know
Styles which one is always like pound
for pound always gonna win so you're
going based off effective not favorite
dude I think it's 50. it's tough there's
so many variables 50 50 between Muay
Thai and Jitsu because what are the what
are the variables is are we ranking it
based on the effectiveness of
self-defense or are you based it on com
hand-to-hand combat hand-to-hand combat
hand in hand yeah yeah yeah yeah like in
a ring yeah
is Brazilian but then it also derived
from Judo yeah right
um so I would say Judo is the most
effective
um because you can neutralize the
strikes hopefully that you don't get hit
yeah and then now you have complete
control whereas the striker he needs
that distance to do something in the
clinch he can strike but against judoka
his clinching ain't gonna really mean
too much yeah you know he's gonna get
tossing up on his back that's okay more
time they got clinched too they do but
if they end up on their back now what at
least with the judoka they can be fine
on their feet and on their back so they
have a higher chance of success because
they they're more comfortable what if a
sumo wrestler comes out of nowhere and
sits on him that's tough that's tough
bro and that guy's like 450. he resigned
you know they're fast too huh yeah
[__] fast and they're hella big and
they can't be stopped either yeah and
they do the 5 000 [__] slap yeah
that's Honda yeah and if they grab a
hold of your underwear you're [__]
yeah off the ground if they get you by
your whale tail dude yeah they're gonna
rip that banana hammock right off
yeah yeah buy your garter belt how
stretchy underwear is now these days
like I don't think those techniques are
as effective but by that time by that
time is that more of an athlete versus
athlete versus for sure martial art
versus martial art yeah you know what
I'm saying because then you would have
to be like a hundred and like let's say
70 pound kickboxer versus 170 pound sumo
wrestler that would make it equal right
not like 170 pound kickboxer and a 450
pound sumo wrestler I guess it depends
on my the ethos of the fighting style
like if like a monk comes in he's like
Shaolin best way to defuse any size
enemy they're like all right let's see
it dude okay you know what I mean what
about a judoka versus like a sumo
wrestler in a locked room good shot both
are naked with walls up like that dance
okay good shots
can compete with a wrestler you know you
know and then also oh their rules are
there no rules no rules dude no rules
how about this what rules what Zuma
doesn't know how to hit they only know
how to manipulate the position they do
know how to do this thing they do that
[__] they [__] shove people dude
they're basically just throwing your
weight off your momentum yeah and but
they're [__] strong I feel like if I
got hit with one I was like get knocked
out dude pop strikes bro are there
Knockouts in Sumo no well they're so
[__] big on each other but if you hit
me I'm I feel like they could punch each
other like they could slap each other
oh like slap fighting yeah bro slap
fighting which no no rings no rules
if somebody comes at you and this is
their style you're gonna take them out
every time
oh hey he takes them out for me yeah oh
yeah I'll just punch him
but I'm really good at it you know Rod's
very good at punching whatever that's
what I know you know just like an MMA a
wrestler is in trouble even though
they're a good Striker they're gonna go
back to what they know which is
wrestling you know like uh you do you do
dancing let's say you take out ballet
right you mess up in the middle of your
ballet set what are you gonna go about
to go like punching you're gonna crop
[Laughter]
what is cerium XM Satellite yeah today's
video is brought to you by Lumi all
right me to tell you the truth I am not
a deodorant guy I used to wear deodorant
all the freaking time in high school
until one day someone told me you know
that stuff is harmful to you and I was
like for real so I did my research and I
was like yeah I couldn't believe it
there's Metals in there it's disgusting
and on top of that I'll even smell so I
just use cologne once in a while if I
stink but now that I'm religiously
always working out and I don't have time
to take a shower immediately after the
gym I just like wished I had something
to clear and freshen up just a little
bit but thank goodness we got Lumi here
which is a whole body of deodorant
it's a whole body deodorant meaning I
could just rub it on my forehead on my
armpit on my butt crack and everywhere
yeah because originally it was invented
by OB GYN it was supposed to be for the
hoo-ha and you know that's a very
sensitive place and because it has to be
perfectly ph balanced for the huha it
actually works everywhere else so if you
got smelly Parts anywhere inner thigh
under boob armpit whatever they'll take
care of it at the source it doesn't
cover up the smell it prevents the smell
from even happening and like Joe said a
lot of other deodorants got some harmful
Metals but this one's aluminum free
paraben free baking soda free and it is
perfectly ph balanced to use all over
your body my favorite smell is a clean
Tangerine
but they also have fresh Alpine they
have very nice smells like lavender and
stuff like that you definitely gotta
check it out so if you're looking for
somewhere to start the Lumi starter pack
is perfect for new customers it comes
with a solid stick of deodorant the
cream tube deodorant and two free
products of your choice like the
deodorant body wash and the deodorant
wipes and on top of that you get a free
shipping that's a special offer for
listeners new customers get five dollars
off the starter pack with code OTR
alumedeodorant.com that equates to over
40 percent of your starter pack when you
visit Luminate deodorant.com I use the
code o t r did someone tried selling
that to me the other day I didn't even
know it's still around what is it it's
like a Korean wrestling thing seriously
oh yeah is that I'm saying it wrong oh
Assyrian or Syrian s-y-r-i-o it's like
it's like but it was on physical one
yeah physical 100 there were a ton of
dudes that specialize in that yeah and
girls yeah it's like
s-s-i-r-e-u-m they might be spelling it
wrong for English is it like Korean Sumo
or is it like yeah it might be Korean
Sumo you must be a good wrestler because
you have a really nice body yeah it's a
Korean restaurant
Korean wrestling a folk folk wrestling
style in traditional National how good
is that oh I assume that's like a Greco
let's see yeah I just don't know the
history behind it to know what came
first right because there's Mongolian
restaurant yeah it's crazy and it's very
similar and they're grabbing pants too
what about that wrestling thing where
they grease up yeah leather vests like
that fraternity party yeah
no there's like there's like a real an
actual traditional wrestling form like
what are we talking about where they
Lube up
have you seen they do yeah they're like
all like greasy stuff like WWE and they
like squeeze each other it's like a real
it's like a real one I've seen on Old
School yeah yeah yeah right what do you
want
Spice channel
it's a classic I forgot what it was
called it's rated R it's family friend
yeah I feel like you're getting your
pornos mixed up how about it do you
think you could beat three capoeira guys
attacking you at the same time dude
yeah
how about two karate guys that are red
belts yes wow no I have I have an
extreme confidence in my abilities to
hurt people in a physical manner that's
scary that's so [__] cool to have how
about just 10 regular women that aren't
martial arts at all that's tough because
my uh and they're really old
but they're trying to kill you bro yeah
I would run I would run I would just run
I would find the the first point of
escape and just get out of there I might
face I might like stiff arm one you know
just to send a message ah don't do it
and then create a line of escape and
then just pull no way Rod would arrange
them in a straight line and push one and
they'd all fly I'm trying to find his
perfect opponent I was I was a bouncer
at a bowling alley once and there's this
giant dude like six foot plus tall and
like probably 300 pounds but like like a
pro wrestler looking dude and uh we kick
him out and then out of nowhere he runs
back through the front and the bowling
alley was crowded it was like a
nightclub bowling alley really strange
um and you see him just sprinting
through the crowd and you see people
flying out of the way
he runs up trying to beat some dude and
it was freaking it was like straight out
of a movie and then um and then I go and
I jump behind him he's like Galloping
like a freaking horse because I'm tiny
you know and I pull him back and then I
drag him out the side door again and um
but I I didn't realize
I was choking him so he passed out like
halfway through the hallway and he fell
on top of me I was like oh shoot this
freaking sucks and this is where reality
hits in like dude someone big enough
lays on you there's not a whole lot you
can really do because physics comes in
because especially with 300 so she was
dead wait dude my lower half was like oh
my gosh like there's no hip excuse I
have no hips I have no hips
no no luckily you know I had a whole
team there so they they rolled him off
of me and then uh we we finished that
whole situation but uh nice you killed
him I love it
he took care of that job
at a bowling alley out of all places
yeah crazy no pulse yeah Dead when's the
last time like you got your ass handed
to you
um
uh the fight right after that I lost
also I lost because I walked into a
punch and I was like that's a fluke
right because everybody's like oh you're
supposed to destroy this guy and then so
uh I fought again against Albert Morales
uh he was like a UFC vet and uh he
knocked me out with the same exact punch
for me doing the same exact thing I was
just chasing him around I was like okay
in my head same thing in my head like
when I lost the first time like I was
like I was just freaking unloading on
him like he was on a verge of death and
then like we broke apart like he was
holding on for dear life and then we
finally broke apart and my head was like
all right let's finish this guy and I
walked and all of a sudden I closed my
eyes I woke up and I'm like did I just
lose
that sucks
and then the same thing happened again
because I didn't learn my lesson and so
I'm chasing this guy and I knew my
head's like all right I beat this guy so
I was supposed to beat him I got an
entry I got I got introduced to go
introduce I got an invitation go change
Demetrius Johnson afterwards uh to help
me either get in the UFC or getting a
one and then you know and I'm chasing
him around I hit him a couple times and
he's like running running running
running and then I closed my eyes and I
wake up and the ref is there he's like
and I'm like ah did I just lose oh man
to the same
situation again I'm like fudge and I
watched a tape and sure enough it was
like you could put him side by side do a
remix on Instagram and she's like me
just walking and me going
and then waking up and then it was then
I was like okay maybe I don't chase
people anymore maybe I keep my hands up
maybe I get more technical now um that
was last time I got beat up uh but as
far as like getting beat up beat up or
like in training like are there any
times like your training Partners like
piece you up or like that's a no that's
a no that's a no if I've ever seen one
dude zoom in on that he's all I'd ask
him but they're all dead
the job's finished
[Laughter]
what about uh your coach uh Romy oh I'm
like twice the size he's like a one but
he doesn't he doesn't piss you up
are you guys are like equals now it's um
the size difference is too great oh yeah
how come I'm way bigger than me but you
whoop my ass yeah why is that right
that's not fair The Experience Gap is
too big oh too many variables see that's
not fair yeah that's [__] huh yeah
yeah I uh
yeah no um uh I haven't I haven't got my
I haven't gotten my butt handed to me
for in a bit so you feel really
confident with like 99 of the world
that's serious and it's weird I know I
feel like Superman but uh you should
feel like Superman yeah I literally have
zero fear of any like human being
um as far as like physical L Ron Hubbard
that's pretty [__] cool
um yeah it's a great feeling everyone's
scared of L Ron Hubbard in the clear
trunks
but that doesn't mean I would put myself
in a bad situation you know and because
I've done so much personal I have so
much experience with personal security
like when I take my family or friends in
the area I'll I'll have a good gauge of
whether it's a safe environment or not
like we'll walk into a place and I'm
like oh I better keep my eye on people
so I'll I'll lock on a certain like
targets that I think that maybe a
Potential Threat to us and I just keep
my eye on them for the rest of the night
um and so like I'm I always have like a
security like
mindset mindset from doing that from
doing security for so long but it's in
my nature to protect others I suppose
dude Ron's [__] Jason Bourne dude
tight can you uh be security for my
apartment complex yeah yeah yeah the
car's not getting stolen oh I was uh I I
suck with music I don't know much about
music but uh I was supposed to do
security for a plus so
plume really is that that's tight is
that a type of dolphin he's like the
biggest he's like he's like a big
Mexican artist right now he's huge oh
that's he's just playing that's right
you always know who these artists are
I'm gonna start playing them in the gym
and I was like this guy's kind of tight
whoa he does like like new age stuff
with like kind of like a like a
traditional Mexican song oh yeah Geo
played for me it's supposed to be like a
huge artist I didn't know he's got a
sick little Edgar haircut have you seen
his haircut it looks like yeah he's like
super big up and coming he looks like
Chavez but you're supposed to be you're
supposed to do personal security for him
yeah I was supposed to help uh uh do the
event because they had 200 guards for
that event and he had like 10 personal
security guards and so um my friend has
a company called bolo protection
services and uh he got contracted to do
it but he didn't enough guys he was like
hey uh you're in security can you help
me build a team so I I had contact still
so I built I brought over like four or
five guys wow that could vouchable for
him and I was gonna lead it but
um April my wife pulls she has the power
to pull the family card at any time yeah
yeah so that [__] [__] pulled the
car
oh dude
[Laughter]
yeah I'm not scared
I said man not one man ah okay
technicalities
what did she say she says [__]
Disneyland day or something yeah she's
like I haven't seen it a bit like uh she
didn't have to say specifically she's
like hey you want to go to dinner oh wow
and that cancels out everything yeah I
already know like
um you're a good guy's so busy so I
wonder what Nick's thinking right now
when Tiff is just like hey I want to see
you one of these can't do it I'm like
what dude I'm gonna go hang with pistol
Plumas
[Laughter]
yeah and it's only because like uh you
know my family I only see him two three
hours a day and then if I have to work
longer then I don't see him at all you
know um like Renzo today like I'm not
gonna see him until like 9 00 p.m
tonight when I get home and I left at
like 6 a.m this morning
um yeah yeah so it's uh
yeah the balance so if they if they pull
the card I'm like all right cool so like
at any point in time if I drove here you
know luckily that wouldn't have happened
because she's out of town for work and
then Renzo's with the nanny right now
but uh oh bro just break up I'm chill
right there can I bring him next time
yeah we're gonna go off the record with
him yeah yeah he'll respond now he'll
talk dude that's awesome he'll steal
some beans nice but dad's a [__]
actually
shoot I was giving him a bath uh I'm
giving him a bath last night this is
probably a little too TMI and like he's
four years old so he's like learning
what's right and wrong and I'm just
getting on the back he's like Dada I'm
like what he's like what's wrong with
your wiener I'm like what do you want
what's wrong with my wiener it's uh it's
Cricket I'm like what I'm like not we
why are you looking at that you know
look at that you look at your own weiner
[Laughter]
yeah you know do you feel like your
wieners crooked let's take a look you
didn't know until then huh so it was
leaning to the left
because the water you know the water
just like he knows what crooked is
that's that's now gonna show up on your
fight stuff crooked as your weakness
he has no weaknesses except for his
crooked penis in water though only in
parentheses 145 pounds leans to the left
that he's crooked but not how you need
not what you think
dude that's the best comment look at
your own wiener yeah I didn't even know
he knew the word Cricket yeah yeah
seriously how do you know what a crooked
wiener is I'm like who are you hanging
out with yeah like who are you talking
to who else is giving you a bath Oh My
Boy tell me all the homies all the
homies
foreign